hello I'm Greg Sadler I am the president
and founder of reason I 0 which is a
company devoted to putting philosophy
into practice one way we do this is
through online courses and I'm very
excited to be able to tell you about a
new online course that's beginning June
nineteenth very soon it is on Plato's
symposium one of the greatest works of
Western literature one of Plato's
greatest dialogues a very rich and
interesting text that has to do with
love sexual desire friendship and of
course philosophy so this is a four-week
class entirely online taught by myself
and I've built a lot of really cool
elements into it so I want to tell you a
little bit about the class and for those
of you who don't know me already a
little bit about myself and offer this
as an opportunity for you to learn by
enrolling in this online class let's
talk about the basics for this class as
I mentioned it's a four-week online
class running from Sunday jun 19th all
the way into july to saturday the 16 and
what we do in the class is hold weekly
class sessions i have the class
structured into weekly modules covering
some of the material from the text or
covering certain topics and each week we
have a class session on that saturday i
actually scheduled two different times
so that students in different time zones
can more easily make the class sessions
we also record the online class sessions
which we carry out using a web interface
the free conference call and so what
this means is you can take this class
anywhere in the world you have access to
all the course materials from wherever
you happen to be even on a mobile phone
and you can participate in the weekly
class sessions anywhere that you have a
good intern
connection so this is a class which is
of a college level you could say in
difficulty but it is not being offered
through a traditional college or
university it's being offered through
reason I up that means that this is not
a four credit class so you can't
transfer this in however this the
emphasis here is entirely on student
learning so this is for personal
learning personal enrichment personal
growth if you want to study philosophy
this is a great venue to to do that we
will be using a course management system
called Moodle in order to house all of
the course resources and we'll be using
free conference called calm in order to
do the video sessions where I interact
with you the students I mentioned
educational resources and that is one of
the great values for every one of the
classes that I teach I do this no matter
where I'm teaching whether it's for
reason I owe whether it's for a
traditional college or university or for
an educational startup I believe in
providing learners with as many
resources to help them get through these
difficult and debts but very rewarding
philosophical text so what I do is I
create using the Moodle course
management system an entire online
learning environment that's filled with
a number of resources that you'll find
helpful as you work your way through
this classic text of philosophy what are
these resources well I create lesson
pages which are essentially like blog
entries anywhere from 500 to you know
3500 words about the the subject
materials that were studying I create
YouTube videos for this class I've
actually created all of the videos in
advance although I might add
few new ones as well they're placed in a
sequence so everything is is in the best
order for student learning possible I
also create a lot of handouts and
sometimes even worksheets that students
can use in addition to that I create
online quizzes that you can use to test
your reading knowledge as you're working
your way through the text and the real
heart of the class besides all that
great you know material to help you work
your way into the text is the
discussions that we have so i use
discussion forums which are interactive
and students engage not only with myself
as the professor but also with each
other as fellow learners so we create a
you might say community of inquiry
around the text in addition to that
we're four tier two students and I'll
tell you about the difference between
tier 1 and tier 2 in just a moment there
are assignments and for every assignment
I provide students a lot of guidance and
that's on the front end and a lot of
feedback on the back end so if you're
taking the class and at tier 2 and I
will provide you with assignment sheets
with with rubrics for performance and
sometimes even with with sample
assignments that other students in the
past have completed that are
particularly good so you know what what
to model your own work after one of the
values that we believe in very strongly
here at reason I oh is that education
whether face-to-face or online should
not only be of the highest quality
possible but it should be made
affordable that's one of the real
tragedies of our own time where many
students are unable to go to traditional
colleges or universities because of the
cost so for that reason we keep the
tuition for these online courses as low
as feasible we have two different tears
tier one which offers you access to
everything within the learning
environment including the handouts the
lesson pages videos the discussion
forums the weekly sessions that we hold
including the recordings of those
towards that costs a hundred dollars so
for a four-week class we're talking
about twenty-five dollars a week
extraordinarily inexpensive for the
value that that we're providing here for
tier two this is for students who want
to get more of an intensive experience
who want to complete assignments and get
detailed feedback from me the instructor
who want to engage in that writing
process back and forth the course costs
two hundred dollars for the four-week
course that provides access to
everything else and that detailed
feedback the other thing that I should
mention is that one of the perks that I
offer to students in these classes if
you don't know already I do individual
tutoring via Skype and normally i charge
75 dollars an hour I offer reduced rates
for students who are enrolled in my
classes who need extra you know
intensive work on some area so if you
enroll in this class you can actually
save yourself quite a bit of money if
you wanted to study that's this taxed
and you needed somebody to work at it
with you'll naturally want to know what
we're actually going to be doing in this
course and I've broken it down since we
had four weeks into four main modules
each of which is going to lead us
through some important aspects of the
text the first week we're spending
essentially getting our feet wet we're
not going to be tackling portions of the
text except for the very beginning for
their own sake although I of course I
long for students to read and reread
this text as many times possible since
they'll get so much out of it each time
so we'll talk about in week one is the
nature of the symposium as a platonic
dialogue and how it fits into Plato's
philosophy in general we'll also talk
about why this symposium which is
supposed to be a drinking party turns
out not to be a party oriented around
drinking but instead giving speeches
about love and how the nature of
symposium has changed over time do
this particular text and we'll talk
about the key themes which include love
and philosophy and politics and
relations between you know men and women
and all sorts of other interesting
issues we'll talk about who the main
characters in this dialogue are the
people who are going to be giving the
speeches and then look at the complex
structure of this dialogue which is
really a story within a story then in
week two we're going to examine the
first three of the speeches they're all
sitting around in a room and they're
giving speeches in turn they'll actually
do it a little bit out of turn with the
third speaker but you'll learn more
about that if you take the class so
we're talking about the speeches by
fingers Pisani asst and the doctor Eric
symmachus in Week three we're going to
look at the middle two speeches by the
great comic playwright Aristophanes you
may have read some of his works and in
other places and then we're going to
look at somebody who's supposed to be a
tragedy and you know the opposite of the
comedian but turns out much to be two
turns out to be much more of a retro and
that is Agathon the host of the party we
for which is what we're going to be
concluding with we're going to get to
the very heart of the dialogue and look
at what Socrates himself has to say
we're also going to look at the speech
that his is the person he claimed to
have taught him all about love this old
wise woman he encountered in his youth
the ottimo gave him and we're going to
look at the ladder leading up to the
highest good that love offers to us and
then we'll look at the day to month that
occurs as a drunken Alcibiades the the
lover of Socrates bursts in and gives an
impromptu speech not about love but
about the object of his love Socrates so
that's what we're going to cover in this
class you may be wondering why take the
class in particular with myself dr.
Sandler and so I should give you some
reasons to mull over one of them is the
fact that I have been studying this text
reading it and rereading it for over two
decades and I had the opportunity while
I was a graduate student just to work on
my my greed to spend an entire semester
doing precisely that in one-on-one
tutoring with somebody who'd been doing
that for 40 years so this is a text that
has stuck with me and I've been thinking
about it for quite a long time and I
hopefully share some of my reflections
with you it's also a text that I find
particularly compelling as I said rich
in ideas but also beautiful the text is
about the beautiful but itself is
beautiful and fascinating and I would
love to share some of my passion not
only for the symposium and the speeches
and the characters and the ideas but
also for platonic philosophy with you
and lead you into it because once you
start to see that the picture that Plato
provides it's really quite inspiring
I've been teaching this text itself for
quite a long time but I've been teaching
philosophy for almost two decades now on
one years shy of that I've been teaching
philosophy online for five years for
traditional colleges in online startups
that were doing innovative stuff and now
for reason I owe on my own so I've put
in a lot of time to think about how
students learn and how to make the
learning experience as as enjoyable as
you know productive and you know
something that's really going to remain
with you over time students come away
from my classes with a really solid
understanding of the text the thinker
where they fit into the history of ID
is how their ideas might apply to us in
the present and that's because of all
the work that I put into the class so if
you're interested in taking this course
with me on Plato's symposium starting
June nineteenth it's going to be a great
four weeks you can click on the link
below which will take you to a type form
below meeting in the video description
and whether you're you know running to
an OLE right now or considering it or
you'd like to get more information or
you would just like to be put on our
mailing list for future classes click
the link that will take you to that type
form you can enter your information and
we'll get back to you very shortly
there's 20 seats available for this
class if there's sufficient demand we
may consider opening a second section
depending on scheduling so you want to
you know get get your reservation in as
soon as possible got several weeks
before we begin the class but I'm
anticipating there's going to be a high
demand for for this particular class so
if you're interested in Plato if you're
interested in the symposium if you're
interested in love and what not only
philosophers but all sorts of other
people from tragedians to two comedians
to military commanders to doctors to
philosophers and had to say about about
love this is a class that you don't want
to miss